thanks very much to the organizers and
by meets Berkeley I feel like it's the
home of twitter i think half the people
i follow seem to be from berkeley so and
the uber app has lots more features in
San Francisco's Wow so okay so I'm going
to talk about a class of modeling class
of modeling strategy which we're using a
lot so it's a kind of something that I
think people should consider adding to
their toolbox for analyzing data we
found it to be very useful and I'll give
some examples of different ways we've
been using it and so I'm going to talk
about Gaussian processes which our way
of doing nonparametric regression I'll
give a quick intro and then I'll discuss
a bunch of different ways that we've
been using these in different kind of
applications to genomic data so a gas in
process for those with the physics
background they be familiar with these
as models of stochastic processes but in
statistics and machine learning they
become synonymous with various types of
regression and classification task and
and so we think of them as very flexible
functions which you can fit the data and
the key object in these guys in
processes is the covariance function and
the covariance function determines the
properties of the samples from this
distribution so it's a distribution over
functions analogous to a Gaussian
distribution over numbers and so you're
drawing these functions and they can be
static or dynamic smooth or rough and
stochastic they can be stationary
non-statutory they can have structure
like periodicity or they can be very
kind of chaotic and so the covariance
function has a form and parameters which
kind of tune the behavior the functions
that you draw so this is a random
distribution over
functions so let me give you an example
so this isn't a gaussian process this is
just a regular guy to distribution okay
so but it has a very specific covariance
matrix and i think on this monday but i
think you heard all about covariance
matrices on monday and so we choose the
covariance matrix which has this high
kind of diagonal here and that means
that things are close together in these
25 dimensional vectors so I'm going to
draw 25 dimensional vectors from a
Gaussian distribution with this
covariance indices which are close
together will be more highly correlated
and when you do that the 25 dimensional
vector if you plot it along the index
index like this it starts looking a bit
like function so you know if you join
the dots it looks like some kind of
smooth curve so guys in process is just
where you take that limit formally to
infinity so you no longer have a
Gaussian distribution over 25 points you
have a distribution over these infinite
dimensional vectors or functions and and
you know the way I've generated these
curves in the computer is actually by
generating Gaussian vectors which just
have so many points that you can make
than that anymore so these are just a
thousand points instead of 25 and these
particular curves were sampled from this
covariance function and so this
particular covariance function generates
smooth infinitely differentiable
analytic functions which are marginally
Gaussian so means that if you look at
particular index the distribution of the
values to get here for this function
follow a Gaussian distribution and any
finite set of indices is going to
generate something from a multivariate
Gaussian distribution and that's that's
the definition
of a gaussian process any kind of finite
set of indices are take has a jointly
multivariate Gaussian distribution and
that makes it very convenient to compute
over these objects because we can do all
sorts of nice computations with Gaussian
distributions so bayesian regression 101
with a gash in process before I see any
data so I'm being bayesian I already
have some pretty strong beliefs over the
kind of thing I'm going to see so so i
think i'm going to see some population
gene expression data so it's going to be
smooth because it's averaged over
millions of cells okay and so I'm going
to hallucinate some kind of gene
expression profiles and these are draws
from my prior distribution okay so this
is before I've seen any data I believe
I'm going to see these kind of Wiggly
functions well I see one clean data
point with very little observation noise
then I'm constrained by the data and my
belief so now I believe that I've got
these smooth functions but they're going
to go close to this data the more data I
see the more the data constrains me and
so my posterior distribution over the
functions that go through this data
becomes closer to the data and the
osteria variants or the credible regions
become tighter and then if I have a lot
of data I see that this was actually
generated from a sine wave and the
nonparametric nature of this kind of
regression is quite powerful because
it's very flexible in the types of
functions that I can fit here but the
prior is also quite strong because my
prior was that the curves would be
smooth these kind of analytically
infinitely differentiable functions and
so there is a strong prior but it has
this nonparametric flavor that I can
model quite arbitrary shapes as long as
they have the right kind of smoothness
characteristics
okay so my first kind of application is
to modeling batches batch effects in
kind of time course data and then how to
do clustering while taking into account
those kind of batch effects so this is
data from this nice paper about gene
expression in different drosophila
species but we're just going to look at
one of the species and you can see that
these are these different batches where
they did these time-course experiments
but I think it the point where they got
to the fifth one they thought oh we
better do a bit longer because the
biology is getting kind of interesting
at the point where we stopped doing it
so they did a few extra time points but
then maybe their budget ran out so then
they thought well compare not do any
more of these early ones because you
know we haven't got budget so we're just
going to do the ones at the end here and
then they give the data over to the bio
informatics team and hair like what what
are you doing and then then then we can
kind of come in and say oh this is a
great example for gaussian processes so
so we can kind of deal with this so you
know the usual thing you might do is
just kind of lump all the data together
you might just concatenate all the time
series or you might average if you lump
it together you're losing all the within
batch correlations which in time series
are incredibly valuable you know so you
really don't want to do that with time
series you don't want to throw away all
that valuable within batch information
if you average and you're losing your
information about what that batch
variance was so you're through also
throwing a lot way lot of information so
those two approaches are very suboptimal
so instead about what you can do is you
can try and model the batch variants and
we use a kind of additive hierarchical
model so you have your kind of mean
behavior of the gene across all the
batches and then each of your batches is
another Gaussian function with that kind
mean behavior so the mean of the
Gaussian is added to by another random
function which catches the within batch
kind of behavior so it's a kind of very
structured noise model if you like with
with temporal correlation and then you
get this kind of covariance matrix here
and it allows you to basically model the
variation across all these different
batches so you can see for instance this
one here comes down much further than
this one up here and it's a temporary
correlated kind of structured batch
effect so you can kind of model that you
can also extrapolate away from the data
by borrowing the information from the
other replicates so even for their cases
where you only updates at the end you
can make predictions about what would
have happened if you've had data earlier
and and actually they're quite nice
machine learning applications of
Gaussian processes where you can for
instance with weather stations deal with
what happens when a particular station
gets knocked out when you're measuring
weather patterns across the ocean and
you can kind of use this borrowing of
information from the other weather
stations that kind of impute the data
that you're missing so that's quite a
nice feature for missing data you can go
on and extend this hierarchy to do
clustering so now instead of just having
genes and replicates i also have
clusters of genes and now what you do is
you have all the different genes in a
particular cluster this is a cluster
behavior but you also have all the
replicates along here which you're
modeling and so you can really capture
this rich kind of covariance structure
of the genes within these clusters and
we kind of plugged that model into an
existing probabilistic clustering
algorithm for this particular for the
same data so it's exactly the same
algorithm that someone else had used but
we just plugged in our particular
covariance bottle and it really changed
the clustering we got fewer
which were more correlated with kind of
biological annotation but that
particular algorithm wasn't too fast so
we also developed a very fast version of
a deal a process mixture model a
nonparametric kind of mixture model so
that you can do this genome-wide and
there's some nice code for that which
James hensman has produced then we have
for Jupiter notebooks where you can play
around with that stuff which James is
also them oh one thing I should say a
nice thing about using this kind of
model based clustering is that you can
put structure into your cluster models
and one thing that people often want to
do for instance is model periodic data
and so experimental group in Manchester
work on circadian sort of
tissue-specific circadian clocks took
our clustering algorithm and then we put
a periodic Gaussian process covariance
into that and did some clustering over
there kind of periodic gene expression
data yes in this case we learned it is a
hyper parameter but I think we had a
prior to keep it within the kind of
circadian range yeah try to maximize the
total evidence possible yeah yeah
actually we have a nicer periodic
covariance function now which has just
been published which allows you to model
very non-sinusoidal periodicity like top
hats sawtooth all that kind of stuff so
it's really nice for non-sinusoidal a
lot of the methods for detecting st.
circadian genes for instance are highly
biased towards sinusoidal genes but
clearly lots of circadian genes aren't
sinusoidal because you use the core
clock to decide went to some specific
time when you want to turn something
like four o'clock in the morning so lots
of circadian genes aren't sinusoidal and
I think most methods are highly biased
towards sinusoidal rhythms so there's a
nice preprint that you can get okay so
the next example is branching and
bifurcation kind of processes and this
is quite recent work and and so the the
first example is where you have to time
course and you want to determine the
point at which they begin to diverge so
basically you do experiment where you
have a perturbed system and an
unperturbed you take a time course and
then you want to work out where is the
first point where the perturbed time
cause deviates from the wild type
behavior and and that's really actually
very easy to do Gaussian processes is
very natural and so the kind of model
i'm going to use now is one where you
have a gaussian function but at some
point another guys in function branches
away from it but they touch at this
particular point here so we can sample
from the prior so this is our prior
here's another sample here's another
sample okay so these are all gasp room
functions which touch with that
particular point and you can work out
the covariance for two functions
crossing so
imagine you have to gasps Ian samples
from gaussian processes this and they
cross a very specific point and that's
the constraint that those two functions
have to cross there and then imagine you
have two data sets so you have some
green ones and they go along here and
that's a wild type but then something
happens to the other data set at the
crossing point and that data goes along
here so the crossing function covariance
is this guy here
this
but then if I have some data which comes
from the joint part first and then
splits then this is covariance of that
data that comes from that kind of spring
process and the nice thing about this is
it's exactly tractable so I can actually
work out the likelihood of this whereas
previous approaches you had to use these
kind of quite difficult approximate
inference techniques this is exactly
tractable this model and so I can just
work out the likelihood for all possible
splitting times and I can just compute
the posterior exactly by just doing a
histogram and just normalizing so
there's no proximate inference snoep or
a variational base or anything like that
it's all exactly tractable Bayesian
inference which is quite unusual
actually to be able to get away with
doing something like that means that i
can compute multimodal posteriors over
this splitting point so that's quite I
think that's quite nice you can do that
and it's very kind of well calibrated in
order in simulated data from different
kinds of scenarios where you have a
splitting point so you can really work
out the rank order of where these
splitting times are quite precisely
compared to naive approaches where you
might just choose the first point with
the differential expression goes past
the threshold that approach is very
poorly calibrated because the way that
you get false discoveries will depend a
lot on where the perturbation time is so
I think this kind of Bayesian approach
really is very well calibrated some way
and so we we've kind of applied this and
we've got paper which is impressed and
there's a preprint on the archive where
we've used it to kind of try and
disentangle what happens when you disarm
a kind of pest for these kind of tomato
plants and and you can kind of look at
this as a new way of doing differential
expression analysis in this kind of data
but one quite excited about is that this
branch in gaussian process you can
actually generalize it
too many different branches you can work
out the module likelihood so you can
actually search for the optimal number
of branches in this kind of data and a
really a nice application this is to
single cell data okay so a single cell
data you often have some kind of
branching dynamics and you want to kind
of learn about what the branches are
where they are how many branches there
are and so on and that's what we're
currently applying that branch in Model
T this is a projection using something
called a bayesian GP IBM which is a
nonlinear PCA plot so this is non-linear
pca of the cells and then this is some
kind of pseudo time along here so
instead of a time series we now have
some sort of pseudo time basically it's
a much harder problem because you have
them first at a time and you have to
infer where the cells are on the branch
in pound so so it's kind of a tough one
but that's kind of the current work it
to you to present finally these methods
are also applicable to simple
differential equation type models of
dynamics so in this work we had some
pole to data and some RNA datum we
wanted to link that in order to
understand the delays in the RNA
relative to the pole too and and people
have done this with a number of
different approaches and this is one
kind of way to do which which I think
has some nice features so you have a
rate of change of the RNA is assumed to
be proportional to the amount of pole to
which you have at the three prime end of
the transcribed region so you just
measure pole to after elongation is
completed and we're trying to understand
how this this whole process is kind of
regulated when we did this initially we
can get really good fit for all the data
and its own
there was some delays in the system
which we couldn't quite understand this
in too big so we put in a delay term
which is some kind of delay that happens
after elongation is complete but before
you see the mature RNA so it could be to
do with transport at the nucleus or it
could be something to do with release or
we don't know exactly where that delays
in the system but we just put it in as a
parameter to infer and we model the pole
to profile as a Gaussian process and
then it turns out the whole thing is
exactly tractable and you can work out
the joint distribution of the mRNA and
the po2 is a joint two dimensional
Gaussian process so everything is
exactly tractable in terms of the
likelihood i'll just show some examples
so we're interested in this delay
parameter this is the posterior
distribution for the delay so this is a
gene which is quite early active but
there's no real evidence of delay here
and then this is one of the ones which
looks like it's got delay the po2 comes
up then the mRNA comes up and it can't
be explained just by the half-life of
the mRNA it looks like there's something
in the system which is really delayed in
this particular gene then that one has
some evidence of a delay if you look at
some jeans though the it's not trivial
because the mRNA p can be after the pole
to peak in jeans which have no evidence
of a delay because they have a stable
mrna so the half-life here is quite long
so that means that you get delayed peak
in the mRNA relative to the pole to you
so that's why the differential equation
is useful to interpret this data but you
can see the data is very noisy and so
this kind of probabilistic approach is
quite useful for this kind of data you
can't just you can't just join the dots
and and with this kind of data and so we
found these really large processing
delays in about ten percent of genes and
we look for correlations of different
genomic features and so on and we found
that
the highly delay genes were enriched for
short jeans so often it was short jeans
with in terms of the pre our mRNA length
which were delayed and there's also some
intronic features which were kind of
correlated with delay and we suspected
that perhaps some of these short jeans
so so we felt that with the short jeans
elongation would be very quick you know
because the elongations who have
happened in about 4 kb per minute and so
these things are basically elongating
about 2 minutes something like this but
they often still have quite complex
structure in terms of introns even
though they're sure there's still long
enough to have complexity and we fell
there may be splicing would be something
involved here and there was some
evidence previously that some genes were
delayed while splicing is completing we
don't know where the splicing could
happen so we looked at the intronic
reads in our data because we had total
RNA seek and um it did seem that there
was evidence that the delay genes tend
to have more increased retention of late
introns over time so we can came up with
a kind of metric for determining intron
retention over time and it seemed like a
lot of these delayed ones have evidence
that the introns are retained and so we
think there's some evidence that at
least for a proportion of these highly
delay genes that's something to do is
splicing but it's only a proportion
there could be other things going on and
there's some very interesting recent
imaging work showing that also transport
at the nucleus can take much longer than
people thought originally and so we
don't know exactly what because of that
is but am quite complicated right
because you have really a population of
cells
and this differential equation is sort
of true for a single cell but then when
you see how much Paul Tudor is you're
looking really at the sort of a
population as yeah that's true I mean
this is a highly synchronized scenario
where you take a bunch of cells and you
hit it with a stimulus and so the short
ones are the ones which are actually
doing stuff quite early usually so we're
hopefully and still in a fairly close to
the highly synchronized are but you're
right i mean everything is smudged out a
bit by the fat view of a cell population
actually we have a model of elongation
which i'm not talking about using
gaussian processes where we explicitly
model the spreading among the cells in a
kind of elongation model and we needed
to do that to get robust result for the
polti moving along in long jeans so yeah
that was really important in that
elongation model i think is this one is
a short ones the signals a bit sharper
so okay so hand porn is it well
elongation time seems to dominate for
most genes over this kind of delay that
we saw but there is a sort of subset of
genes over ten percent of genes where it
seems that this delay that we see is
actually more important than elongation
time in terms of determining how long it
takes to make the mature RNA so so it
seems like it's a kind of significant
effect for a proportion of jeans
we can also extend this for a time
varying degradation when when that's
under regulation so that's quite
challenging because things become non
exact and the whole gashing process
approach and yeah I mean it's a bit of a
whistle-stop tour of different
approaches where we've used these but i
think i'm sort of selling the
methodology in this talk so I like
gassing processes because they're got
good mixture of flexibility
intractability okay so hopefully you've
seen that you can do kind of
hierarchical modeling very nicely with
these you can introduce structure like
periodicity and the models remain
tractable under constraints like
branching and bifurcation and they're
tractable under linear operations on the
functions so if you do a linear
differential equation or a linear
partial differential equation and
spatial system the whole thing remains a
Gaussian process so the likelihood
becomes is exactly tractable in those
cases you can make compounds kernels so
if you have a periodic process but it's
got a trend then that's really easy you
know so you can it's really easy to make
compound models which have features of
lots of different models and that's
actually really important to be able to
do because usually a signal isn't just
purely periodic usually it's periodic
and kind of varying in some other way
data is often non-gaussian but they're
really good approximate inference
algorithms and a few people have
recently published camp based models
using Gaussian processes so using canned
data but modeling it with Gaussian
processes the two groups have just
published papers modeling I think RNA
seek data using that kind of approach
and and importantly the codes base is
kind of growing and we work a lot with
Nia Lawrence's groups package called g
pi which contains a lot of different
types of covariance function which you
use and adapt and there's lots of nice
Jupiter notebooks to show you how to use
that DP flow is a very exciting
development from James hensman and Alex
Matthews where they take tensorflow
which was designed to do kind of deep
learning gradients you know because
computing gradients is a big part of
those applications and apply it to GPS
so that means that you do have to sit
down and do the derivatives and actually
the differential equation work aunty
uncle ads do about 125 terms and one of
the integrals in that paper so it it
looks simple but the covariance function
was quite hard to deal with so GP flow
could really speed things up there and
there's some are packages like the ones
we've produced and and this is the
project where we collaborate
collaborated a lot with near lawrence
anti honkala and james hensman has done
lots of the work and lots of the coding
here and jinyang did this time
perturbation model and Alexis and Max
had been working on the single cell data
and that's it thank you I'm scuri sir
Cohen ho kohonen the self-organizing
networks a bit of the same flavor of is
there a connection there or could you
think of this is a generalization of
that so the closest connection with the
self-organizing maps is the GPL vm which
is a lame variable model where the
gaussian process is used as a mapping
from a low dimensional space into high
dimensional space and so it has very
much that kind of flavor i guess yeah
yeah
ascaris in the in the branching Process
Model so in the one you drove like a
father is to smooth curve and they're
branching where the brushing is not
smooth like a trajectory in summary so
is it father the model always a model no
symmetry to other two branches that the
model for the single cell data is
symmetric but the one I showed for the
time series is not symmetric so on the
time series model the wild type is
smoother than the perturbed so the idea
there is that you have some kind of
smooth behavior and then you perturb the
system and summing shoots out of the
side you could constrain the first
derivative to be the same at that point
and that would lead to a smoother
branching but you can't constrain all
the derivatives because it's an analytic
function so if you can strain all them
that they'll be the same forever so you
can only constrain us one or two
derivatives yeah ask you are there any
other suggested consistent with nice
properties like and let you said ginzu
Gaussian process so there's a lot of
different nonparametric funk and lots of
nonparametric approaches for discrete
data not for a kind of smooth functional
data I think the Gaussian processes are
the most tractable for inference other
stochastic processes I imagine are
rather difficult to do inference with
so I can't one ring a right to follow up
and then could you think of a model
where like the lamina from a Poisson
distribution is what's model with the
Gaussian them but then there's okay so
people use guys so people use Gaussian
processes for that yeah so people do
that in modeling spike spiking data in
neural kind of measurements and then you
must model the lambda from the prasun
and you do is a Gaussian process and
they often if you have a lot of data you
can use these kind of path integral
techniques to actually infer so so
actually when when the process is
engaging in physics will they often
expand around the dominant path using a
gash and expansion anyway which is like
a Gaussian approximation guessing
process approximation to something so
it's kind of related to path integrals
and all that kind of stuff yes I also
want to be about Harmons because they're
in the gene expression case the way I
would sort of physically think about it
is that there is some smoothly varying
rate of transcription but then the
actual number of mRNA is there fire RT
some for salsa yeah it's quite easy to
put non-gaussian likelihood functions
into gaussian processes so for instance
log cox models and spatial statistics
models often have discrete observations
and they use Gaussian processes as the
model over a rate course something like
that you know and so you can do
inference over a discrete distribution
but then the inference has to be done
with the proximate inference techniques
if you do amazing imprints but they're
clearly tractable so you can do it yeah
ok well let's thank all the speakers of
discussion here